des images de sport pour débuter ce
journal et les bonnes performances des
yvelinois aux championnats du monde de
cyclisme sur piste qui se tenait à hong
kong le trappistes benjamin thomas a
remporté notamment deux médailles d'or
de son côté ligne et montrent un
françois pervis n'est pas en reste le
pistard de 32 ans a remporté une
médaille d'or sur le kilomètre son
quatrième titre mondial dans cette
discipline et le bronze en vitesse aussi
par équipes pour lui la france grâce
notamment à ses bonnes performances
termine deuxième au tableau des
médailles derrière l'australie avec cinq
médailles dont trois en or